welcome back to Las Vegas now your
insurance agency the sponsors of this
segment have some tips on saving money
while selecting your annual Health Plan
I stopped by to learn more
we are back here at your insurance
agency Chris we're talking tips to
saving money for your annual health plan
right correct and one of the things
that's unusual is where we start is
really with money with what our income
is so why mention income is because
insurance is expensive and based on our
income there could be resources to help
you offset or help you pay for your
insurance premiums so whether you're
under 65 and you're on an individual
family plan there could be tax credits
available to help you pay for your
insurance
or if
[Music]
insurance through your employer you
obviously could have there could be
resources there to help offset some of
those costs or ideas that we may be able
to bring to your attention and for those
that are over 65 we also have resources
available from the federal government or
state to help offset some of those fixed
costs as well now what about those
people who apparently make too much how
did they say that is a great question
for those that are high wage earners
there are programs that are there to
help assist them offset some of those
costs so when you sit down with the
broker some of the things we have to
determine is it better staying with your
current plan through your employer is it
better to stay on the exchange where you
get your tax credits and or other
resources there to help give you
discounts sometimes we're able to bundle
services that someone's looking for such
as Dental hearing vision and Etc that we
can actually bundle and give extra
discounts so we do have solutions for
high wager nurse but we also have
solutions for everyone else so we have
the tax credits to The Exchange now that
doesn't phase out which has been
extended through a couple more years
through 2025 where we can get tax
credits but also a new law that was just
patched we call the Family glitch now
this is a new one but basically what it
means for those that have insurance
through work
and it's unaffordable we may now be able
to get tax credits for their family to
get insured through our state exchange
so you seek a broker and we can help
with those Solutions as well and also
one last tip is that if you're willing
to take a smaller network of doctors to
choose from there's discounts for that
too as well okay now does all of this
apply to life insurance too
actually yes we do have life insurance
that do have some extra health benefits
on there our biggest tips for life
insurance are the riders that can be
added so if you already have life
insurance look to see if you have some
of those extra benefits such as
long-term care accidents cancer heart
attack extra benefits to help offset any
of your medical expenses that you could
have if you do become ill with your
health insurance now with all of that
said Chris what is the most universal
tip that I can use people watching can
use when it comes to health insurance
use a knowledgeable broker
a broker that has multiple lines of
insurance that doesn't just sell one
thing they can sit and have a
conversation with you and through that
conversation it's amazing what comes out
and what people's needs are and that we
can help solve their entire family's
needs
your insurance agency for sponsoring
that segment call
702-425-5500 or just head to
y-i-a-n-b.com for more information we'll
be right back